do the freaks in the press make it
impossible to guess
yeah it seemed the media's priorities
make us overestimate the size of
minorities groups that is
in a new study americans were asked to
guess the percentage of various groups
in the united states
and like my clothes at one of hammer's
hot tub parties our guesses were
completely off
for example people thought nearly a
third a third of the country was gay
the actual number 80 no i'm kidding
three percent
transgender people were estimated to be
21 of the population when it's allegedly
0.6
in reality
perhaps some of the non-binary people
may have been counted twice
study participants guess that jewish
people were 30 of the country when
they're actually closer to 2 i didn't
know that and african-americans were
estimated at 41
compared to 12. i haven't seen this many
exaggerations since january 6th
nice one greg
thank you that's god
but it gets sillier
people thought 30 of all u.s citizens
lived in new york city
a democrats wish and another third live
in texas well a lot moved there from new
york it's weird did these people decide
30
was the right number for everything
well it is would i tip the duces when i
have them walk on my back
anyway
these questions weren't that tough how
do people this bad at math even survive
wow that is a lot of candies yeah how
many think are in there like four or
five
are you serious well not more than seven
seven
hey did you pass me a box of tissues
what do you mean like pick it up what do
you want me to rent a forklift that's
probably 90 pounds
i'll do it
whoa
check out she-hulk over here
all right ted i'll see you later i'm
crossing the street right here watch out
for the traffic what are you talking
about those cars are like 500 yards away
i got plenty of time
uh r.i.p
kat this is true in so many places like
i was thinking there are fewer tennis
players
that merit an interest in wimbledon
i don't know anything about tennis see
what i mean you prove my point do you
notice this trend
yeah i guess i was shocked by some of
the numbers though i don't i don't think
it's only three percent of population is
gay i think it is 30
really yeah
of your friends
like 99 of my friends are gay yeah so
like adjusting for my sample size 30
definitely gay so they were wrong on
that one um dana this i could tell you
love this story
we're talking about it but it it does
have consequences i mean people have a
really distorted sense of like police
brutality because remember democrats
thought that it was like uh the the
number of unarmed black men killed by
police numbered in the thousands
crazy and then it turns out that it was
something like in the less than 100 well
it's like actually a two dozen including
white and blacks white white victims and
black victims yes and so and i was
reading it thinking well this is how i
explain to my husband when i buy all
these things that i think are on a
discount i'm like oh it wasn't a 40
discount it was a 4 discount oh i didn't
realize that um this is a big problem
though for people who are trying to
estimate like
what we should do in terms of inflation
right what is the policy prescription
like their answer is buy an electric
vehicle but that costs 80 000 yes yes
that doesn't make any sense yes kill
your pet charlie could this be what is
keeping propping up identity politics oh
absolutely if you had the real
information identity politics would
collapse well and i think that's the
whole propaganda game that's going on
and and yes it is true americans are
probably pretty bad at math i speak for
myself i i i cannot balance a checkbook
but uh the the good the silver lining
here is americans are also really bad at
demographics that's not the way they
look at one another we look at one
another as just being sort of we're in
the same doing the same thing we have
same interests we don't look at people
based on demographics the only people
who do are the media and they can't stop
but i have to make one thing that makes
me wonder about some of the numbers here
um they said that 88 of americans
actually own a car
but only 83 percent have a driver's
license so there are five percent of
people out there who own a car but don't
have a driver's license i was that
person for a while you know going rogue
i could understand it the other way
around i don't understand well maybe
they were sleeping in their car charlie
yeah
or that makes no sense or maybe
maybe they uh own a car but they drive
it like beto and they lost their license
you know what i'm saying like one of
those deals but then why are they being
honest about it to somebody that called
them up on the you would think that
would be something to lie about yeah
i want to ask you does your wife
overestimate how much you don't look
homeless
i don't know like i don't ever think i
look homeless
i think i i think i do i look like i'm
running like a liberace tribute band
over here
where i'd have at least the tour bus to
sleep in i don't think homeless is fair
i think the reason the estimates are
high
is the end result of identity politics
in that everybody wants to act like
they're living an inclusive life
oh i'm surrounded by gay people and
black people and transgender people
everywhere i go and you want to sound
virtuous to the guy
of course it is
of course it is but it is amazing to
think that transgender people are only
0.6 percent of the population and
somehow have 33 of the gold medals in
swimming that's
great impressive was a great joke and i
can't use that tomorrow yeah sure you
can yeah maybe people are forget
some groups are you know yeah and some
this day and age we're just playing
we're playing this up i actually think
that that number might be lower but
you'll never be able to know because now
you have gender fluid fluid
it's influencing that so it's like the
authentically trans the person who goes
through the surgery and whatnot uh is
probably smaller but inflated yeah don't
forget there's currency in claiming this
type of status now yeah no matter what
it is if you claim to be a you know
member of some type of minority or
marginalized community that's now like
give me something you know what i mean
so i'm with you the only one i don't buy
is four percent bisexuality that would
not fly in my search history
[Laughter]
up next when it comes to kanye the
grammys say no way